hello and welcome to the new ultra view
yo sauce for everything anime and manga
and today we're here to talk about a
series that was recommended to me after
I mentioned that I really haven't seen
all that many sports anime being haikyuu
now I will admit that I was quite
skeptical going into this but enough
people brought it up that I decided to
give it a go regardless I mean
volleyball was never really an interest
of mine whatsoever but who cares let's
try it anyway and in retrospect there
was no reason I should have ever been
reserved about this anime IQ thus far
has been an enjoyable journey that has
really struck a chord with me because
while I never played volleyball I did
play both basketball and soccer and of
football anyone where you live in what
you like to call it and the core ideas
and relationships of teamwork are
exactly the same just applied to a sport
that I had no knowledge of beyond the
simple actions of dig set and spike and
I would argue that having no knowledge
of volleyball is actually probably the
best way to consume haikyuu
because it does slowly introduce the
basics of volleyball in a way that I
feel like may have frustrated me if I
was already a veteran of the sport
however instead it has been a lot of fun
to see volleyball slowly expanded upon
and built before my eyes and through
these absurdly likable characters and
before I go any further I just want to
say that I've only seen up until the end
of season 1 I do definitely plan on
watching the rest but I felt like I
wanted to get this video out now because
god damn and I'm just so excited about
2d characters playing volleyball and
fulfilling their strangely specific
volleyball related dreams and that
brings us to our primary protagonist
Hinata he starts out being exactly what
I expected from a series like this you
know the infinitely determined driving
force of the series that inevitably
Helms just about every shown in property
in existence but he had me on board from
the very first episode it was
simultaneously admirable and crushing to
watch all of the effort he's put into
this love of volleyball just to be
convincingly defeated in his very first
official match but experiencing that
defeat with him is what tied me to
Hinata emotionally and made me want to
go on this profound journey of struggle
it's actually odd because he's such a
simplistic character to the point where
on paper I feel like he should annoy me
he has a one-track mind he's a bit of a
derp and in the anime he has a
particularly piercing voice but the
thing is that even though his existence
is so laser-like that's also what I
can't help but admire about him because
I don't think I've ever felt as
passionate about anything in my life
as Hinata feels about volleyball I
actually cannot imagine being in a
situation where I am so profoundly
driven that I would make
the sacrifices that he does that's very
eye-opening and inspiring actually off
to every episode of haiku I feel like I
a want to immediately go and play
volleyball will be failing that do
something incredibly active like go for
a run will see failing both of those
pour all of my energy remaining for the
day into my own passions which is
generally just YouTube these days and
it's not just Hinata who is responsible
for generating this kind of amazing
feeling it's the entire cast each of
whom have their own unique perspective
on volleyball and its impact on their
lives but on the court
everyone unites to serve a common
purpose and it's nothing short of
glorious to watch Kageyama obviously
deserves a mention he's kind of like the
auntie Hinata a genius fun parallel
gifts who can only make the most of
those talents by learning to work with
the most unlikely person imaginable and
it took me a relatively long time to
actually start liking Kageyama
but once again seeing his absurd
dedication to the game and his own
personal struggles with it can't help
but win me over in the end and he really
is such an essential aspect to the
series he and Hinata are more like her
protagonists and I can't wait to see
where their partnership takes them in
future seasons but I actually don't
think there's a single character on the
karasuno team that I dislike probably
the person I feel most neutral about
Asuka Shima but that's very much because
that's how his character has been
betrayed up until this point you know
the kind of neutral apathetic being who
after his initial role in the first few
episodes has spent the rest of the
series just kind of being there he does
have his moments and I'm sure that he'll
probably have his own story thread going
on at some stage in the future but for
now he's the one who I generally care
about the least which is actually very
complementary to the rest of the cast
many of whom I love to death already
another favorite of mine is nishinoya
because it's always nice to see an
energetic powerhouse and someone who is
short in a sport that is primarily
dominated by Giants he also has a really
nice pin on him which is his focus on
being a liberal but I have to say that
some of the most charming characters in
the series are the ones who see very
little action on the court at all and
the first person who comes to my tía is
suka wada
i spent a lot of season one feeling
terribly sorry for him because being a
setter was his thing he's clearly
passionate about volleyball but when you
have a genius like cocky ama coming
along it's hard to deny that he is the
one who should be playing the set a role
but thanks to the sheer brilliance of IQ
characters like this do kit that you
recognition and sugawara x' moment where
he is brought onto the court to replace
cocky ama is one of my fondest memories
in the series thus far showing that hard
work does pay off in fur
while he completely dominated the game
as a result plus he also works as a
brilliant contrast to carry Amma
really showing us the versatility of a
setter and how different mindsets can
put unique spins on the position which
to be fair the setters of every other
team in the series also do this quite
effectively but it was much nicer to see
it coming from sugawara because of how
he dealt with the exact same team that
Kageyama had to work with and i could
probably go on and on and over every
member of the team like this but I'd be
here all day however the one final
character I do want to give some focus
to is Yamaguchi so if Hinata and
Kageyama are the driving force behind
the series and Yamaguchi certainly
represents its heart and soul
he is average in almost every way
imaginable he almost never gets on the
court and the one time I remember he did
he failed immediately and was taken off
fail being subjective of course because
I guess he didn't serve his purpose but
at the same time he just keeps going
regardless which in some ways is so much
more admirable than Hinata or Kageyama
because his struggle seems infinitely
greater than theirs he does have the
same desire that everyone else on the
team has and he works hard to achieve it
he just doesn't have the ridiculous
talent or physicality that everyone else
sports which is why I'm Iguchi is so so
important because he is the eyes of the
average viewer and I hope more than
anything that at some stage he does get
a real moment to shine because I have no
doubt that he will be working hard
enough to deserve it what I will also
say about haikyuu is that it is
incredibly addictive due to its format
especially when it really gets going in
the second half of the first series like
as soon as the tournament began it was
almost impossible to stop watching
episodes I felt like I needed to know
the outcome of every game and even after
a game was finished I found myself far
too eager to devour the next one and two
just keep pursuing things to their
natural conclusion I think that is part
of the general appeal of tournament sir
and why they tend to pop up and shown in
series even when they're not sport
related but one potential negative I
will say though is that the locations in
high Q can become just a little bit
stagnant which is something that I guess
can't really be helped because due to
the nature of the story the characters
will either be training which will take
place in the gym or they'll be playing a
match which will take place in another
gym elsewhere and while the gyms do have
subtle differences it can end up feeling
more or less the same and that would be
an incredibly detracting factor if the
characters weren't strong enough to take
command of the series without that
visual backing however they are good
enough to stand alone so there's that
personally I do wish that the aesthetics
of the series did have a bit more flow
I would love it if every gym or
tournament arena and a radically
different appearance but at the same
time that wouldn't really fit the style
that the series is presenting which is
undoubtedly realism I mean yes there are
moments in play where Hinata and the
other characters will pull off some
absurd moves that look completely
impossible to achieve in reality but
other than that thank you is very
grounded in the real world and with that
in mind I guess it does make sense to
have these realistic locations but do
more or less look the same like standard
gymnasiums would but I can't help but
wonder what would have happened if
haikyuu took more of a food war style
focus though where it took this
realistic activity and pushed it to its
stylistic limits whilst being able to
maintain a solid character focus it may
have helped it probably would have
hindered and I guess in the end it
doesn't really matter because this
series as is managed to hook me
regardless it doesn't stop haikyuu from
taking you to deep emotional places all
over the spectrum in fact quite possibly
the most impactful moment to season one
for me is after car sooner loses the
inter-high tournament and the whole team
were at a restaurant in complete silence
with tears streaming down their eyes and
just being told to eat and rebuild their
muscles it was such a bittersweet moment
I mean mostly bitter I guess but it was
coated in hope because the general idea
is that from this moment they will only
get stronger this defeat was a necessary
step in the continued growth of the team
and that next time they would go further
and further and I love that and oddly
enough all of this really struck me
because one of the things that I think
made me so hesitant about sports anime
is the concept that winning is
everything
and even then I guess I do have to admit
that most characters in haiku are
heavily focused on victory but honestly
that is one of the things that made me
fall out of love with soccer and
basketball that overwhelming drive to
win was imposed on us by the courage and
other teammates and I was always more
interested in having fun with what I was
doing rather than looking only towards
victory so I was a bit surprised how
easily I got on board with something
that I'd very much been fighting against
my entire sporting life but I suppose
that is the greatness of IQ really I get
to live vicariously through these driven
fictional characters and in the meantime
I can use my life to live it exactly how
I see fit but I still get the experience
of the profound highs and lows that
victory and defeat deliver through this
brilliant series so I am a bit sad that
I've put it off for this long but at the
same time I'm incredibly excited to
watch more high Q and possibly even
explore other great sports
which you know if you have any more
recommendations do feel free to drop
them in the comments below but for now
to conclude I have to say that I am very
impressed with what Hank you has to
offer thus far it's done a wonderful job
of crafting characters who are easy to
empathize with and be able to truly feel
their experiences as a result it's a
fantastic ensemble piece and I can't
even begin to imagine the growth that
everyone is going to undertake over what
is a two more full series in two films
ah I've got to go so we're going to
leave this here so that I can go and
delve into more haikyuu and that pretty
much does it for my initial thoughts and
thank you if you enjoyed this video and
the content this channel produced in
general then please do consider donating
to the new world review patreon because
the support of all of your amazing
people is what continues to make this
channel possible and if patreon isn't
quite your style then please do leave
this video a like share or subscribe
because it also helps support this
channel an incredible amount and if
you'd like to join the fun at any time
then please do head over to my discord
server where a wide array of shonali and
rey takes place on a daily basis and
finally please do comment with your
thoughts on haikyuu
this has been the new world review and
I'll see you next time